doing something okay
so i think we can start so just to say
thank you all for you to for coming for
your interest
i hope that um you've been able to look
at the conservation area appraisal
documents that are online on the um
planet district council website we've
got some consultation pages all the
information is up there
and the there's still time so following
this meeting if you've got
suggestions amendments etc um the
consultation will close midnight monday
the 13th this coming monday and so
there's still time for you then to
submit your suggestions onto the
consultation webpages
um
and
yeah just to give you i know some of you
have already been working closely with
us as conceived members from the
heritage and design forum and other
volunteers who helped with the initial
assessment so some of you have heard
some of this before but um for the
others of you who are kind of new to
this
we've been working over the last year to
kind of put this appraisal together
so um with it's it's funded by historic
england a house project and we've been
working with tdc planning officers
also our climate change and home energy
officers
um
and yeah we're just really keen to um
get as much feedback as we can
on the on the draft and the next step
once we get um the
once the consultation closes on monday
we'll then be reviewing that making
amendments and then the kind of final
draft will go forward to council
adoption in the new year
um
but i'm very pleased we're very lucky to
have both john and richard from alan
baxter consultants with us today who are
going to kind of give you a bit of an
overview of the work that was done on
the appraisal
highlight some of the key
recommendations and then we'll um open
the floor for questions and answers and
we've got about 45 minutes before then
we'll try and wrap things up
so if that's okay i'll pass over to you
john
great thank you i'll pass straight over
to richard for some introductory words
before i take over backwards and
forwards right hello everyone thank you
very much um uh pleasure to see you all
i can see both of you anyway so right we
haven't got a huge amount of time so i
won't dilly dally i wanted to just say
very briefly what the objective of this
document is
and then john will talk a bit about um
what we've uncovered and then i'll
finish up with a little bit about
climate adaptation and that aspect of of
the document so what are we trying to do
the key thing is to understand
and to put down on paper or the internet
um
the understanding of the character and
appearance of the conservation area
that's the critical thing character in
appearance those are the words of the
act the 1999 1990 act why does this
matter because the council has a duty to
in considering planning applications
within the conservation area to preserve
or enhance its character and appearance
so if through this document and your
engagement we can agree collectively
what that character in appearance is
hopefully that will lead to greater
clarity in planning greater certainty
and greater consistency so that's what
we're trying to retrieve that's what
we're all trying to achieve
and because it's such a big and rich
conservation area
in order for that to be useful you have
to do that in quite a bit of detail
hence it's quite a long document and
there's a lot of character zones but
that's in order to make it helpful in
every street and not so kind of overall
and strategic and generic that that kind
of analysis of a character appearance
doesn't apply
um to different sites so that's the
first thing and then the second thing
is managing the conservation area it's
really a kind of road map it's not the
detail but it's hopefully a collective
view of what the future management
should be
in order to conserve it and conserve
what in this case is undoubtedly a very
very special place
but doing that in a balanced way because
it's the planning system to enable
development to take place but in a way
that is you know consistent with its
conservation and that means looking at
everything from whether the boundary is
correct um with the appearance of the
streets and clutter and things like that
the future of empty space
and how we are all going to have to
adapt towards our changing climate which
is something i will come back to
after john first has said some words
thank you richard yeah and hello
everyone uh it's fantastic to see such a
healthy turnout and it's to be expected
i know how
enthusiastic
everyone is about ramsgate's heritage
i'm going to get a nice image up on
screen
now
please make a noise if you can see
liverpool lawn
yes i'll take that slightly yes hooray
we've all got our microsoft
very very good mic discipline i like to
hear that
um
so yes uh i'm going to very quickly whiz
through uh the process we went through
to take the data we received
from thanet district council in historic
england to make it into a usable
appraisal for
decision makers
local residents visitors to ramsgate um
people looking to change the built
environment uh in ramsgate
so people know as richard said the
captain appearance of the conservation
area and also
set out a series of management
recommendations for uh the cons uh
conservation and enhancement of that
character appearance in the longer term
uh and i'd just like to start on this
image which is obviously very well known
to everyone um but i think it summarizes
uh the sort of do's and don'ts of the
conservation area so in the foreground
you have a beautiful crescent of
liverpool lawn with a huge
survival of original features original
windows railings etc
in the background you have
post-war redevelopment that wasn't quite
as respectful of the built environment
as
uh hopefully it might have been today um
and you know in terms of form and
appearance
it's quite intrusive
and then in the foreground again you
have uh very recent developments at the
southern end of liverpool lawn which is
at the polar end of the spectrum to the
opposite end of the spectrum to the um
kind of post-war redevelopment
in uh
you know going the full the full way in
producing something that
really fits in with with the surrounding
heritage context
um
it's vital to to say at this stage
straight away that the help and support
that we had from the local volunteers in
particular the ramsgate historical
society has been utterly invaluable and
is actually the bedrock upon which the
conservational appraisal is based and
before we got involved in december 2019
a huge amount of work had already taken
place to uh understand the character of
uh the different parts of ramsgate it's
a huge conservation area
um hence the 13 character areas which
i'll go on to but um it took an army of
volunteers uh many many hours to go
around and
understand
the the positive negative neutral
aspects of the conservation area
where improvements could be made
um certain aspects that are you know
particularly worthy of preservation
and so the volunteer data was the key
informative for us and it's as i say it
formed the basis of everything that we
put in so in that way
uh ramsay conservation appraisal is very
much a document
uh produced by local residents and four
local residents rather than in other
parts of the country where that may not
be necessarily the case always
another important document is of course
the recent historic england book
on ramsgate it's a fantastic study
and freely available online as a pdf and
if you don't know about it yet i highly
recommend you get
you get yourself a copy
it's a very comprehensive study of of uh
rumsgate's seaside heritage and towns
heritage
of course carried out
a number of site visits and trying to
distill you know a lifetime's worth of
knowledge about a town into the space of
uh you know three or four days in the
town is is uh no easy feat but i think
after many hours walking around and
understanding the extent of the
conservation area and the 13 character
areas we developed a fairly good
understanding of the town
and ultimately we used uh gis mapping
data um to that was provided by historic
england and state district council
to
get onto the skin of the town and
understand the kind of historical
development patterns
and patterns of of character and
appearance and that produced the 13
character areas that you can see on
screen now and the characters were a way
of breaking down uh the kind of overall
the overarching character appearance and
overall special interest of the of the
conservation area into um kind of chunks
and
neighborhoods and areas that had a
slightly more cohesive character
and the idea there is to produce a
series of chapters within the appraisal
that are um you know complement the
overall the overall chapter and are
useful for
uh people making decisions or residents
living within these areas to understand
uh
you know the distilled essence of
ramsgate in their particular part of the
town
using the gis data and our own site
visit data and the volunteers
information
we were able to map out the special
interest of the character areas
into um hopefully quite clear
and concise mapping so we lay out the
listed buildings
buildings that we consider to be
positive contributors so those are
buildings that aren't listed but um are
of some heritage interest and contribute
to the current appearance of the
conservation area
tree preservation orders and positive
green spaces which are of course
you know vitally linked to
the special interest of the town
and also opportunity
opportunities for enhancement so areas
that
may
have degraded over time or buildings
that are in need of
some sort of conservation work or sites
that may be suitable for development in
the longer term
and views maps as well which
show
some of the key views and sites that
should be protected
and enhanced within the
conservation area
so
the final document as it came
as i say is structured around three main
parts we have uh part one which is the
appraisal and that's split down into a
series of chapters looking at each of
the 13 character areas that produces a
summary of the various aspects of
character
for each character area
and is specific to that character area
obviously
the second part of the conservation of
appraisal is the
management plan
which i'll whiz to in a second
and the management plan is
particularly aimed at uh the local
authority um and and ramsey and that
district council but also is useful for
uh local residents volunteer groups uh
other people involved with and working
with the council to uh enhance the
appearance of the conservation area and
that lays out a series of management
recommendations
uh for how various aspects of the town's
character should be
improved and enhanced
and as i said the the final piece of the
country appraisal conservation appraisal
is advice uh on the uh carbon reduction
and climate change adaptation to um
understand how in the specific context
of ramsgate
we
will have to change
certain policies and certain build
environment traits in a sensitive way
that protects the heritage of the town
and
in terms of the key aspects that came
out of it for us the kind of key
elements that the um the sort of key
lessons learned i felt that there were
four areas um
that
are very much interlinked but also um
you know needs to be treated in very
specific ways so number one is the
unique green spaces around the town
um which
complement the historic built
environment and are kind of oasis of
green within
the urban environment so you have
um you know
the east cliff lawns you have the
polamite
rock formations and it's
understanding how these should be
managed uh in the future and how through
voluntary work but also
importantly through input from ramsgate
town council and from thailand district
council these can be preserved and
enhanced
the other
one of the other aspects is the town
centre which obviously has some of
ramsey's most historic buildings
but also has a high
rate of vacancy and also some uh
buildings of lesser quality that don't
necessarily fit with the general
character appearance of the conservation
area
and i think it's really important in the
coming years with the high street
heritage attraction zone to understand
how this aspect of the town's character
can be brought up to
a similar level and similar standard to
the residential areas and the harbour
area and the
green spaces which are so cherished and
admired
the residential areas are another kind
of key theme and how as richard
previously mentioned the high rate of
survival of uh of historic
features windows doors uh railings and
what the implications are for residents
of those buildings uh you know we
noticed and we were
um some parts of town there are high
rates of um house hmos um house multiple
occupancy
and what the impact of that is upon
the residents living there and the
extent of change that's possible within
some of these
particularly important and highly graded
parts of the built environment
and finally of course probably the most
important aspect of the town's character
is the raw is the royal harbour
um it's one of the most spectacular
views in the country and uh you know
awash with heritage justice um of course
the character is very different to how
it was uh 100 years ago or even 50 years
ago
and it's about how change within the
port area can be managed um the port
area and also the harbour
used as marina
and making sure that the uh heritage
justice within this part of the town are
enhanced there's a number that require
you know urgent attention for example
the clock house in in
the center of the screen there
and other parts of the
harbor infrastructure um that are a key
uh driver of tourism to the town but
also a you know a vital part of the
town's heritage
and how that can be cared for in the
longer term is a really important
question we have
fuel right
is that me again john
yes if you could have a quick word about
the climate change yes okay so i'd just
like to say you're all guinea pigs uh or
trail blazers depending on how you look
on it because as far as we're aware
well certainly historic england are
aware who commissioned this
this is the first attempt
and it is an attempt
to provide advice
for people in the conservation area
about how to adapt um buildings to
reduce carbon emissions and uh changing
climate
um and we're conscious that it is that
first attempt so i don't think any of us
uh think it's necessarily
you know the last word
but we hope that it's um
nevertheless very useful
we uh wrote it with a fantastic
architect called bob pruitt who spent
the last 15 years
adapting old and historic buildings um
so
therefore we're confident the sort of
practical side of it is grounded in real
experience it would be disastrous if it
came from john and i because we don't
know the first thing about it
fortunately bob does so that's the first
thing so the technical side of it really
is coming from a practicing um architect
who spends his his professional life
doing this
um and i think uh
it it i'd say it's longer the advice
that we anticipated at the start because
one of the challenges that we will all
find over the next 10 to 20 years it's a
very complex subject it is difficult
to simplify it
and
in doing so making it useful because you
get into details quite quickly
and the thing one of the things that
really struck me i hope it comes across
is that you know you can have unintended
consequences of doing one thing
it's a whole organism as it were a
historic building especially so it's
this it's the having to try to think
about the totality what they call whole
house thinking that's not to say you
have to do everything at once far from
it it can be a very
uh
sort of a creative process but you do
need to have an understanding of
thinking about the totality
so
bottom line what does it come down to
well it really comes down to three
things
um
uh when you distill it um for our
climate we like we're already
experiencing more intense rainfall we
have to change gutters and downpipes to
cope with that it's going to get hotter
the summer is going to get hotter we're
going to need better shading prevent
overheating fortunately and lots of
landscape for example we have wonderful
victorian precedence in the form of sun
shades etc so that kind of thing
um to reduce our carbon emissions what i
found absolutely striking is typically
80 more or less of a homes emissions are
coming from heating heating of rooms
heaping of water so that's the critical
thing to tackle
better control fewer drafts improved
insulation window improvements and then
for the whole country as we've been
learning over the last few months
weaning ourselves off gas um so that's
not exclusive by any means um when we
started writing this it really wasn't on
sort of you know on the public horizons
as it is now groundhog air source heat
pumps all those sort of things
um
so those are the two things you need to
do and as i say to wrap it all up you
have to think about how it all goes
together now in a conservation area what
does that mean well it could be can be
difficult there aren't
there are going to be
fewer
um
opportunities as it were than if the
buildings weren't um protected by that
kind of uh
legislation
but i do think and bob we think with bob
that in many instances you can get an
awful long way towards net zero
ultimately by some
not necessarily
that um
difficult uh things uh technical
solutions
um but there will be places and areas
such as you know front elevations of
listed buildings in particular where we
anticipate
that um you there will be restrictions
and all they're going to be restrictions
on on what one can do but for example if
you take windows you know you can get
sixty seventy percent of the benefits of
a double glaze window if you have a well
fitted secondary window secondary
glazing so you can go a long way
without necessarily having in every case
to to you know undo uh the things that
john was talking about the kind of the
detail that makes the conservation area
historic buildings um uh so special so
it will be interesting for everybody as
owners as
professionals as a local authority to
see how we all go on this journey
we hope that this guidance will make it
easier for everybody that's as much the
authority as for you
in going along that way
towards these changes that are coming
um but as i say i think we probably this
will be the sort of thing where in five
years time we'll have to kind of come
back to it and this will be same
everywhere in the country and
and reflect on the advice that we're
giving and whether that needs to change
again because i mean my expectation is
that
uh for example some of the technological
solutions or perhaps the grant
conditions that might come up are going
to change
so it's not a static world it's a sort
of it is that front edge of something uh
and uh we will have to adapt for that
but underneath it the basic principles
of what needs to be done to buildings
and what needs to change i think are
pretty sound it's those sort of
technical solutions and the regulative
framework which may evolve
uh as we you know advance over the next
five ten years or so
so um i
wasn't proposing or and john and i were
not proposing to say anything further
um
rather we would open the floor to
everyone here i think we've got just
about 20 minutes we haven't done too
badly
um so i think yes if you stick up your
little um
hands
uh
and then uh we will take questions
how many hands how many people are we
looking for louise i'm just thinking
i can see one hand so far
is that ivan
oh two more okay i'm going to open the
queue now oh exciting i've never done
this before well the first one
was ivan
hello there hi richard hey sir
vandorencio and richards and mike foley
and we we're members of the uh the local
design forum here um and uh yeah sorry
if you've been watching us eat christmas
biscuits uh
all the time
on the screen um but yeah i think you
know it's an incredible it's kind of a
very large body of work we've just been
trying to look through it
and we did send through some comments um
previously i think on the previous after
the previous
meeting um but we just have kind of four
four kind of questions or sort of areas
that we're kind of interested in or have
a few kind of slight minor worries and
the the major one is that we think that
the the kind of the the table where we
have um actions
for the local authority or the
um or local local
community groups and what have you it's
very it seems to be very onerous on the
standard district council where and
having a um you know that they do this
this this and this
um and i think we've already got a very
you know one of the busiest conservation
officers in the country who's you know
doing a very good job of trying to deal
with a lot of the explosion in
development that's happened and i think
there needs to be just
reiterated that actually there probably
needs to be a conservation professional
either assigned to the um to the project
or there's a suggestion of you know
there needs to be a an office a case
officer or a project officer it would
cost x over five years because i think
that the you know there's a danger that
this is you know
nice big thick report just gets left on
the
shelves because there isn't
the um
sufficient sort of um
capacity for local community groups and
the the conservation officer to actually
undertake a lot of the recommendations
um the third the second kind of comment
is basically you know it is if there is
any scope and apologies if this has been
included at looking at
future extensions to uh of conservation
area or new conservation areas which is
marlborough road and ellington park
and mulva road is an excellent example
of you know a very particular type of
victorian development um that you know
we're starting to see sort of um sort of
slightly you know incongruous
developments there trees being cut down
and what have you um so that's one of us
kind of secondaries the the
third one was the kind of you know the
inclusion of say the 2006 kent design
guide and you know we are all
as the design form we really try and
promote you know uh good design whether
or not that's contemporary design or a
kind of sympathetic what most people
call the pastiche but not not something
in the middle
and i think the design guide you know
2006 it's incredibly old it has some
very good
chapters on sort of you know street
layouts and things like that but it is
quite a worrying design guide when it's
it's you know included in local plans
and policies because it's a very
particular style of architecture that is
focused on and a lot of the president
images are a very particular
middle canterbury
maidstone type of building that actually
bear little relation to what we have as
a kind of a georgian seaside regency
style of buildings and that you know as
it looked as a design form we are trying
to push for a design code that can be
adopted as part of the neighborhood plan
um so perhaps that could be referenced
instead of the kind of defunct
kent design guide um and then the the
the kind of the fourth one sorry to pile
on comments is just the we we do have
some concerns with um
uh the energy efficiency chapter as well
so i don't know if might want to talk
about that or we can send through some
comments i think rather than just like
come out small brush
comments now just like maybe bullet
point
uh
some of the stuff i think is missing i
don't do energy efficiency measures for
older and traditional builders
department practice
and uh
i think uh rather than me just sort of
sound off at the moment
over the weekend i drive down my
thoughts and then forward it
to
to to you guys so that you can
sort of implement it but like uh there's
no real reference to british standards
7913 and in all the pas documents
uh whenever you're dealing with a an
older or traditional or listed building
the pas documents say you should be
using british standard 7913
and
so
that's kind of
one of the one of the points on that but
rather than waste time i'll use up time
now i'll bullet point it and and
send it through to you guys for monday
that would be great and even if
necessary we can have a chat on the
phone and maybe get you and and bob
together we can thrash some of that
stuff out that would be really helpful
um i'll just pass over to john in a
minute just to pick up a comment
yeah point taken about zion guide we'll
certainly think about that
john will talk about the conservation
area future conservation areas i think
the first point and i can see liz and uh
others have joined from and the council
that josie um uh as well um who we are
making reference to i think you know
absolutely um uh it is the you know kind
of death of reports isn't it to just
list the whole load of things that
wouldn't be wonderful if we do all these
things so i think the point about um
capacity is a very good one that we will
take away
i think the other thought i have
immediately is whether actually we
possibly need to
you know take us
identify of all of those things you know
what are really is the top two or three
things that need to be taken forward um
and
if it comes to pass that it's not
possible for all the reasons we're
familiar with to take everything forward
so i think that might help to focus it
as well um and there may be some other
thoughts on that but that's my immediate
response to that so i'd suggest now if
uh
john you talk about the conservation
areas and then if josie or anybody else
wants to add to the point about
resources etc they can pick that up
otherwise we'll go on to the next
question
of course sure so um yeah on the point
about uh extensions to conservation area
and potentially new conservation areas
um so
one of the chapters of the um
of the act of the management plan
outlines the extensions to the existing
ramsey conservation area that we've
proposed um
and they're fairly minor but um i'm
happy to go through those now at later
time if people wish um
but in terms of your point about uh
potential new conservation areas and in
particular the marble road uh ellington
park area which is as you say very
beautiful i was walking through there
um on my way from the station to the
conservation area many times and i was
dropped by how incredible it is and how
it is it does represent that next phase
of development after the regency town
you know it's next phase of growth in
the sort of uh mid-late victorian era
and very well preserved in all cases
it was one that we discussed um quite
some length with historic england and
tdc
uh about
to what extent the conservation area
could be extended into that area um
and i think we the ultimate conclusion
was that
as
an extension to the ramsgate
conservation area
um
it didn't necessarily fit the uh
character of the sort of the historic
harbour town and the regency
resort town however at a future date it
probably does uh justify you know
conservation area designation its own
right but that's not that's outside of
the current scope of
of the appraisal work that we've been
undertaking so that's definitely one
that
you know there's a conversation about
later um i think the same can be said
about uh the area to the uh to the north
of of east cliff the residential area to
north that area which has some very good
quality housing
thank you
see deb schotten
has
deb next i think
hi there good evening everybody thank
you very much for that that's really
really interesting to hear from you
one of the things that um has um
has come to the fore recently in phallit
uh thanks mainly to southern water but
it does raise the specter of rainwater
harvesting because at the moment we've
got masses of grey water going into very
very poor
um sewage
treatment areas and southern water have
been using it as an excuse to dump
sewage routinely into the sea as i'm
sure you've all seen from the news
um rainwater harvesting if we're looking
at guttering can we please make this
something that is considered because
we're doing it in our house actually
does involve us digging a very deep hole
which we're not particularly looking
forward to but um while work is being
undertaken i think it's criminal not to
not to make this adjustment
um because it just makes such a
difference and certainly for new builds
it should just be an absolute
solid gun requirement i don't understand
why it isn't
um one second question
what's wrong with double glazing well
designed
well-made double glazing on the front
elevation of these beautiful houses
because i personally think it's less
intrusive less damaging to the windows
the extant windows
um that with secondary glazing is is
always damp but i remember we had it
when i was a kid my mum always had
little jars of silica gel trying to
absorb the the condensation and
generally speaking it's just a bit of a
nightmare i'm not saying everyone wants
you pvc far from it but there are so
many good products out there now i was
just wondering what your thoughts were
on that thank you
i think
uh
windows improving windows is in many
ways is one of the
most complicated subjects because
there's so much um variety it is one of
those subjects where
it varies so much from building to
building i think it's we've we spent a
lot of time thinking about it and we
found it very difficult to give um
really hard and fast sort of advice on
that
um i would say
um that um
in
particularly uh listed buildings but he
not necessarily exclusively listed
buildings where you know
it's the original slash joinery and it's
a you know early glass or 19th century
glass not necessarily i don't know it's
original glass i think um
there is a general reluctance
necessarily to go for a full replacement
and i think i can understand that
because they are you know an important
part of the character of those buildings
as we said it's it's that sort of detail
which really leaps out in ramsgate i
think
um
having said that um
there are a huge number of you know
windows that aren't like that it gets
complicated when you've got elevations
which got windows from different dates
you know repairs and all the rest of it
so um
one of the you know one of those factors
you know with providing guidance like
this is we you know we can't uh
and this is entirely right and
reasonable we can't fetter the kind of
conversations advice and uh that josie
and colleagues give on an individual
basis and because we can't provide for
every one of those situations
so they will still be required to
negotiate you know discuss on any one by
one basis so i i i still think that
there are going to be those historic
windows where
at the moment the balance is in favor of
retaining them
but i
uh in some respects i am sympathetic to
what you say deb
um and i think it's i mean i would just
say
speaking as a sort of professional sort
of slightly outside the specific report
i think it's going to be a conversation
over the next few years across the
country
about where the balance lies on that
um but at the moment it you know if
you've got a
19th century's ash window you've got
early glass in it um i think you know
that that's certainly realistic and
often if they're not that's a they are
pretty important part of the character
of this conservation area
so that's a roundabout answer because we
did find it a real challenge to provide
sort of clear advice on that it's one of
those examples where it does it becomes
i think about what i said
it's necessarily you get into the detail
very quickly and that detail varies from
building to building
yeah i think just to add to that um you
know i think
i hope we've got the balance right in
the uh the climate adaptation section in
particular but also the uh the
management plan
um in
uh making it clear that it's a
case-by-case basis but also um double
glazing isn't a complete no-no and you
do have situations where there may be um
you know
one of the listed regency terraced
houses in the
town uh that's had all of its windows
it's historic windows replaced by
upvc um that is very much out of keeping
with the character of the conservation
area i think in in those situations
potentially um you know
well-designed double glazing potentially
there's a place for it um but again not
to fetter the judgments of josie and
team
um but you know all things on the
spectrum it's all about good design as
that um
as the design form have said so
um
and it could be i mean there's an awful
lot of posts for window you know you
know joinery isn't there post-war
slashes and all 1930s
you know so
there could be a lot of
quite often come across wooden sashes
which are not 19th century or earlier
and there's a good case that can be made
in those instances because as you said
you can do some beautiful uh
double glazed sash windows these days
so um i'm sure that will be one uh again
i think that's one
exactly sort of subject i think in five
years time it would be advisable to you
know reflect on the guidance in light of
experience i think
harvesting um yeah that's a very very
good point and uh i'll we'll make sure
that um
if that's not included already then
there's uh something said in the report
about it yeah we'll pick that up
definitely now the next one it just says
ramsgate town council is that the entire
town council
or just a representative
i think that's me david green um
[Music]
one of the attractive features of our
regency buildings to my mind
is open fires and tall chimneys
now these are great for dealing with
ventilation and
we're expecting raised temperatures
and and for clearing radon but they're
not so good in terms of energy
conservation do you have any thought any
thoughts on that
well i mean hey sorry go and john
well just a brief point that um walking
around with with bob uh
pruitt the the um
conservation and uh energy efficiency
architect who um helps with the climate
adaptation section he was struck by the
number of extremely tall chimneys and he
noted how
um chimneys are almost without fail in
need of some major work so uh it's a
it's a it's a
sensitive subject in the conservation
world uh you know
the the amount of uh work that goes into
conserving chimney pieces but no you're
right it's it's it's very much part of
the character that roof scape i think
particularly when you're up on east
cliff looking down over
the royal heart that's really striking
how how the roof set kind of comes alive
at that point
um and i'm just as at home at the moment
we want to open up re commission some
fireplaces at home but our kids
won't let us do it because of the carbon
we're a bit stuffed there um uh well
you know
i'm interesting i i don't see it
necessarily uh there's a problem i mean
i agree with john the the chimneys are
very the actual chimney stacks
themselves are very part of the
character i mean would be very uh
disappointed to see those go if people
want to operate them they're going to
have to operate them within the rules
that we will all have to follow in terms
of
um solid fuel etc uh and we
tighten up um so i i don't necessarily
see it as um a problem specific to the
conservation area i think
um and they start to stop within it i
think the options you know speaking
something looking at it now
are reasonably clear at the moment
um
does that answer it or you're thinking
something specifically beyond that
no i just think it would be a great
shame to lose them
yeah well i think that's right i think
so too yeah i think that's right i mean
it's very very and you know the thing is
also they are in
as we've moved beyond the coal era i
mean they are a profound reminder of you
know what kind of powered
the country in the area in which
ramsgate was created they are
fundamental to the creation of places
well you know an entire era in our
history and our buildings and our towns
and our cities and they you know they
are they are very sort of powerful
evocative reminder of that
so i see um
deb has a hand up and so does jill i'm
not sure who was first um
so shall we i think deb was first okay
we'll go with ted first
i'm gonna poke my mute bubble it's my
husband actually phil yes hi
i just wanted to make a very quick
comment um being a close follower of the
science behind
climate change there's been two mentions
now of um
things getting warmer
and while global temperatures are
undoubtedly
increasing the local effects are much
much more uncertain
and there is quite a good chance that if
the atlantic currents change
we could be plunged into much colder
temperatures
and i think the emphasis should be on
extremes rather than on direction
we could be looking at very very cold
winters in this part of the world
yeah i think that yeah well i agree with
that and i think it also reflects
because that's my point about having to
review this in the coming years because
we are as used you know that that point
reinforces it the the point that we are
um still understanding beginning to
understand what's coming so i think
that's a that's a fair point
say gel
oh jill you may be on mute
hello
back on boots again you want to try one
more time just
taking the mute off
see what happens
all right off off mute now
hello did you call me
um
my screen froze so i i couldn't hear
anything so
um yeah sorry about that i i i wanted to
ask question about liaison with other
agencies ie kcc
and you showed a picture of liverpool
where i live and you also showed a
picture of addington street which is a
stone's throw literally from liverpool
addington street had some very pretty
street lights put in
and then followed we were followed up
with some really ugly street lights put
into liverpool lawn which quite a number
of
uh
residents
um disliked and
we consulted
about it with
kcc and they said oh no objection had
been made
um
but but in fact we hadn't been consulted
as residents i don't know who they
consulted when i asked to see the uh the
minutes of the meeting
about the street lights they said oh the
meeting had been a walk around meeting
and consequently there were no minutes
um so it's it's very frustrating um and
i just wondered
a what your thoughts are on styles of
street lights and um
are we complaining about nothing
um or b what we could possibly do about
it in the future
thanks
that's a very good point i think there's
sort of um two things there and one of
them is um that's
uh
you're totally right the
kind of good quality uh good design
street lighting um can make a huge
difference uh to the character of a
conservation area you have the beautiful
um you know converted gas lamps along
the military road for instance and that
you know
even
new uh kind of historicist style
lamps as they have on addington street
um you know fit the character appearance
so hopefully
uh one thing that the appraisal will do
is um provide
a framework and some guidance to
the local authority and other parties
like kcc
um in uh you know choosing appropriate
designs for the conservation area um
whereas previously without the without
the appraisal
uh that that guidance was more difficult
to come by
and i think the other thing is uh to say
is that um
the person who we've um
uh
completely admitted to mention so far
who played such an important role in
writing uh the appraisal does um louise
dandy who used to be a conservation
officer in ramsey in in tdc
um and she uh carried out quite an
extensive consultation with
various stakeholders so um
officers within the council uh i know
she spoke to kcc
uh the highways department for instance
so
um those conversations have gone into
the management plan and some of the
recommendations in there are based on on
uh louise's conversations with those
those organizations i know she was um
particularly interested in kind of the
the tone and the warmth and the color of
street lighting which isn't necessarily
a point that you're drawing on but i
know that she um talked about street
lighting with kcc
and in terms of practicalities of the
consultation between kcc and tdc on
things like street lighting i have to
defer to the council on that i'm afraid
and
yeah i don't know if anyone from the
council is able to pick that up i mean i
just very well just think about that i
think uh we
will need to make sure in the final
recommendations till that is picked up
because i you know you're absolutely
right of course relationships with
highways authorities are absolutely
essential
because in fact obviously the
conservation area they can have it they
have a massive role to play in areas
which are the public areas
so
we will look again at the
recommendations and discuss with uh
fanet how that particular aspect can be
uh
uh reflected um in the final report
because i agree with you and then just
finally on because what should they look
like well that goes backwards comments
about we talk about design dies
i don't think there's a right answer um
it might be um uh that that is something
that it needs to
just need to be finalized whether it's
possible to come up one which is a good
new design for the entire concept
or whether that's um in the process
what's your question to them
yes
most of the streetlight conversions to
heritage style lighting
were done some years ago
through grants from our kcc members
and my wife elizabeth green in
particular financed quite a number of
them
but i think the
our current kcc members have lost a lot
of their grant giving
[Music]
money so it would be more difficult to
do that way now okay
well i think maybe this is something we
could take up when we would come to
revise make final changes to the
document we maybe get in touch with a
couple of you to make sure we properly
address this issue in the final version
of the report
i think we have a stop meeting
yeah we have to stop the meeting
because we've got another meeting i
always
listen you're okay with that you had
your hand up your last one
i have a question
sorry
i think that young council there i know
they had to leave a bit earlier so
that's fine if you need to leave if you
if you want to ask any other questions
you can send them by me if you yeah i'm
glad
yeah
okay thanks louisa
so liz
over to you
hello
everybody just wanted to introduce
myself i'm liz pollard from historic
england i'm historic england's lead for
the heritage action zone in ramsgate
through which his piece of work has been
delivered and i wanted to thank john and
richard and everyone at alan baxter's
for their work and louisa um and josie
as well for um the time that they've put
in from phanet um i also wanted to
champion the important role that the
historic environment has
in climate mitigation adaption
considerations
particularly in the embodied carbon that
historic buildings already hold and
that's one of the reasons why we should
retain and cherish
and maintain and reuse them because that
design
and
build phase has already happened
potentially hundreds of years ago so
that carbon is sitting there captured
and that's one of the
one of the reasons why retaining
historic windows is important because
you're retaining that that would
uh and the materials that have already
been manufactured and created as well as
the traditional skills um that have gone
into creating that that piece of
carpentry um
we are really excited about the climate
chapter as richard said it is a first as
far as we're aware in the country um for
these considerations to be built into a
conservationary appraisal and i'm just
delighted that we're able to do this in
ramsgate um and also historic england is
very interested in looking at using this
as a template um for future conservation
areas and that's that's something that
we we want to pick up
in the future um
i'm also really pleased about everything
else that we've delivered from the high
street house like that sorry
the the heritage action zone um and um
and also how the conservation area
appraisal will bridge into the work of
the forthcoming
high street heritage action zone as well
um i'm going to pop in the chat um a web
link to historic english website um
sorry i'm very much on brand tonight
and
there's a lot about
our work researching climate change um
we've been tasked by government to
include it within our arena i'm
particularly excited about the way
historic buildings
do support climate change and carbon
embodiment um it's a it's another string
to our
[ __ ] um so i'll pop that in the chat so
you can read about the work that's
ongoing and as richard has
also said it's a conversation we'll come
back to time and time again and the
technology is evolving very very quickly
so
um we can't claim to have got it right
just at this point but you know
it's a rolling stone so thanks everyone
thank you liz thank you very much uh
we're no no relation by the way i should
stress
um
okay i can't see any further hands up um
as oh louisa have we got time for one
last question if you're happy to take
one last question but yeah conscious of
time so yeah
david off you go last one
um hi
my question is around the
impact of traffic in the conservation
area
particularly traffic calming but also
issues of safety and of course issues of
pollution
um
these issues are mentioned in in the
documents
uh particularly in terms of safety given
the narrowness of roads and the notice
of pavements um i'm particularly
interested in westcliff road because
that's where i live
and it was noted in that
coach area part of the document
that there is a considerable amount of
traffic
uh the roads roads and pavements are
quite narrow in parts
um
i was i was wondering my question really
is what kind of
traffic calming measures are appropriate
in a conservation area because in some
way it was mentioned that
um
raised beds and hunts and so forth are
rather again intrusive
would something like chicanes or
um you know chicanes that have got some
you know garden area to them if you like
some vegetation
what's the kind of feeling on that
well i mean yeah i think it's a it's a
very good question i don't think i've
got a direct straight answer because
you know they can be uh not necessarily
the
easiest things to sign in
um
i i think i was just wondering whether
that was i was looking at ivan
and that group there were any anything
that you'd ever seen that you thought
was particularly well suited to to
ramsgate's
um
circumstances i mean
so i think that's actually something we
should stay away i think that one of the
things that that makes me think is that
whether or not we should have a few more
um in the final document a few more kind
of precedent examples of the sorts of
things that could be adopted to give a
better sense of of what's possible
and to open uh our ideas
i must say immediately i can't think of
anything that would
tick all the boxes
um
i mean the infrastructure of roads is is
a real difficulty isn't it i mean i
think that's the bottom line um
and uh trying to keep it as lean and
clean as possible is often a good idea
um but and i think that applies to my
mind to materials as well if you are
going to raise surfaces what you want to
do is keep them and this is a principle
it's the the number of different
materials in the in the street
as small as possible
so that they are not um
kind of competing for attention with the
buildings i mean that you know the
street in many ways should be a sort of
a neutral plane aesthetically it's got
all sorts of functions to perform so
keeping that sort of the the materials
as as simple as possible i think is one
of the key things for me and that was
less i remember we did facilities work
in york it was actually the neutrality
and the simplicity of the palette and
materials
was the the main finding there
uh rather than the specific types of uh
of solutions
yeah yeah and then yeah
so just to add quickly to to raise the
it's all the dull footnote but it's also
um you know
everything in the conservation area and
different conservation areas and
different character areas goes back to
um you know what is appropriate for that
character area in that conservation area
and which as i say quite a bland answer
but it's you know looking at west cliff
road as a particular example
um you know it's it's
it's a surprisingly narrow
carriageway for how
how well used it is and how important
the road is leading into an ounce of ram
skate um so the measure's uh appropriate
for that area and you know a street
lined with uh sort of mid 19th century
buildings uh mostly in
you know
close to town early 19th century
buildings might be very different to the
town center it might be very different
to east cliff for instance so
yeah just echoing what richard says um
kind of neutrality of materials and then
um kind of
uh thinking about the the local context
okay
thank you very much
i mean what probably the biggest factor
is
is speed i mean if speed could be
reduced
um say you know to 20 miles an hour then
that you know that one thing will have a
big impact
um i'm aware that simply having 20 mile
an hour zones
and not enforcing it in any way is
probably a complete waste of time
um because i see that you know you might
get as a 20 miler
zone and cars still seem to zip along
there at uh you know excessive 21
the only only thing is some form of
average speed cameras but
you know in a densely
populated area that's quite difficult
because there's so many entrances and
exits
the prime point that would say that
reminder that the answer everything is
not design is it you know i mean that's
a good example of that i mean it might
well be it's about um other other
mechanisms and tools to do with behavior
in other ways um and that's how they all
interrelate with
a conservation area which designation is
originally fundamentally about
appearance and that's how they all
become intertwined together so i think
when we come back to look and talk about
kent cc's role i think that's uh after
this and doing the final version of the
report we will pick that point up as
well thank you very much for making it
okay
i think uh luisa should we wrap it up
there if everyone's happy thank you very
much um for everyone for coming richard
john for presenting and um yeah there's
again there's still time to put your
comments onto the tvc website for the
consultation pages but thank you very
much for coming and
we will be in touch
yes thank you everybody that was that
was really useful some excellent
questions which we shall digest thank
you very much thank you
[Music]
you